hello welcome back to New York Stars
debrief I'm Erik Bosse joining me today
are Philip Malina is my voice yes be
happy to be here wait no that's not my
voice it's similar who's that that's
Maude Garrett hi I'm Lord Garrett and
I'm back [ __ ] welcome back it's great
to have you back and we're gonna be
talking about some Marvel movies on this
episode a new Walking Dead spin-off
that's in the works an edge of tomorrow
sequel like Devin remember the great
movie I was having a Jean Grey moment
fine take that away from me uh if you're
having a busy week by the way and you
don't have time to sit down in your
laptop and watch this whole thing you
could be listening to the podcast
version right now be very confused about
what just happened that's true because
there was a x-rated prop on the table so
you can listen all about it still on the
Himalaya app it's a great place to get
your podcast emily is actually helping
us support this direct show and make it
or you could listen on Apple podcast or
Spotify any any where you get your
product podcast and your podcast and you
could do it while you're partying or
partying or anything you could just be
listening to us right now okay that all
sounds great let's get started with our
lead story this whole idea of what comes
next in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Beyond Avengers in game beyond
spider-man far from home right now we
got Captain Marvel coming out anyone
else seeing Captain Marvel so mod scene
Captain Marvel and Erica and I have nice
little thing every time you mention
Captain Marvel and I don't like what
you're gonna say I can drop a spoiler
okay well don't do that well maybe
compliment me then say something nice
then say something I want to hear you're
very controlling goose is goose is
called goose and not Chewie which is
originally in the comics because I'm
doing a Top Gun theme huh keep going I
feel I don't know I do wanna know he's
actually gonna now mud your I don't like
your so true she's not gonna do another
spoiler there's somebody who's not a
good actor in the film Erik what's going
on with here we go so after Captain
Marvel of course is Avengers endgame
that's gonna be a major game changer in
lots of ways the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so much that Kevin Feige
doesn't want to tell us what comes next
for good reason probably and then after
that comes spider-man far from home
that's really all we know and some
people are saying that might be too much
of a spoiler just by knowing that
spider-man and Nick Fury come back in at
set after an injured end game so you're
saying that's too much to know so you
can understand why he doesn't want to
know want us to know more than that well
right now if you look at the Disney
lineup schedule for the next couple
years currently in May of 2020 they have
listed untitled Marvel film they have to
because it try not to spoil it's great I
love it and they just want to hold the
slot but what they normally buy now they
have filled that slot in and told us
they tell us everything we haven't had a
moment like that yeah that was a snap I
didn't like hearing that there are four
cats at play goofs but only ones well
here's the deal that may 20 20 movies
was going to be guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 of course all that controversy
happened they had moved it back there
were scheduling issues all the stars in
that movie of other projects that
they're working on they had to line it
all up and they have to find a new
director right one can fight you just
straight-up said you know we're kind of
focusing on other stuff right now right
so that's been shelved that's been
pushed back but some other containers of
what that may twenty 20 movies be some
announced movies that they said for face
for a black widow solo film I like that
black panther - it sounds like they
gotta have a black panther - that made
so much money and Doctor Strange - has
been confirmed to happen and got three
Academy Awards are you kidding me black
thank you is that the most winning
Marvel that's only Marvel yeah it won an
Oscar three
I think another previous movie may have
gotten maybe Doctor Strange was
nominated for visual effects but didn't
get it yeah so we have those three black
panther sequel Doctor Strange - in a
black widow movie but as far as we know
none of these movies are currently in
production they got announced crazy
detail they haven't started shooting yet
like again may 20 2010 a year right
right and they're not shooting a Marvel
movie yet as far as we know yeah on
average in most big-budget movies you
need two months to do principal
production on it
that's not counting reshoots which every
major movie goes through in
post-production which takes probably the
bulk of the amount of time on a number
of visual effects I believe most of the
movie does require a substantial so I
don't think they can do it yeah well the
reason I think they've locked this down
is it's a prime weekend for movie
releases pretty much for the past
several years they've had that first
weekend in May they've even started to
get a jump on it and release the past
two Avengers movies or Avengers in game
of inches if any more moved it up to the
last weekend in April so they get kind
of a two week bump out of that and then
no one will really compete with them
that second weekend because it's still
gonna be a popular movie this will be
May 20 2010 months since the last Marvel
movie which will be far from home coming
out this July and that will be a long
amount of time I'm about it right if I
gotta stretch it out a bit
yeah I got a I gotta take a breather
really I see this as there's two
different ways this could go and both
are pretty interesting either we're
gonna have a long amount of time along
like hibernation between Marvel movies
or at least longer than usual for them
because really at most we see maybe
eight months between I mean I mean if
they scrap the day and they end up
saying you know what we don't we're not
gonna put a movie there because we don't
have one in production then your time
but it really will be like a year and a
half or so yeah like that which is a
very long time so that's one option or
the other option which I think is also
very interesting maybe something is in
production and somehow using Disney and
marvel's resources they're keeping it
hidden from us they're keeping it under
wraps I don't know how they would do it
because these are Herculean efforts to
get these movies out involving thousands
of people from piays to set people from
different people agents who have to know
if they're working on things they put it
on I'm to be straight away yeah you
would think there would have been a leak
if something that's pretty in production
or maybe something's in pre-production
right like they were able to keep a lot
of things about far from home a secret
when we knew that movie was happening
and they were shooting all over Europe
you know so there are ways you can keep
things under lid but I quit man filmed
all in Australia I know it was really
under water even yeah
nice day again great think what are we
which way do we think this is going what
do you think they're not telling us
I am theory they pivoting away from
movies because a little thing called
Disney Plus is happening screen producer
had the same theory oh yeah there you go
hey yeah we're on the same page with
that one because when you think about it
we've got how many Star Wars shows we've
got how many Disney shows and the
Disney's the talent that they've got
already like with Marvel right Loki
tim-tom hockey series Duncan Winter
Soldier has a series right Howard the
Duck maybe do the small screen yeah take
on Netflix isn't in cinnamon cinemas you
had sometimes I do that see where I
can't remember if it's cinnamon or
'cimmanon I'm pretty sure that oh I
didn't like hearing that tell you about
oh that um infinity war in game was
filmed before Captain Marvel interesting
just to recap for everyone mod is every
time you say something I don't like he
really lose unto what she won't like and
it's getting really loose as to what a
spoiler me so I can make like a 18
minute video about that I'm not hot and
soulless
I'm obviously saying things that are
available on the internet and the
information is just there if you look
for it if you look at our comments
sections those constitute spoilers
according to some people who you told me
this movie is happening nice to me and
that's something that you're struggling
with so I'm gonna I'm gonna use powers
knowledge is power real quick though on
this topic of what they could be hiding
from us I do want to acknowledge that
it's not like they don't do that I
what's-his-face Brian Michael Bendis has
been like kind of leaking publicly that
he's got something that they're working
on with Marvel and he's just like not
allowed to say what that's a whole movie
by one of the most famous creators in
comics that we don't know anything about
I mean I guess there's some theories
about who could be brothers like a kitty
pryde idea that maybe we were saying
that it that it could be any but that
what's crazy about that is he's like
oh I've got this whole Marvel movie
coming it's related to the x-men
he's like it's definitely happening and
yet we know the Disney Fox mergers come
in so is he actually talking about a
phase four x-men movie and he's just
kind of casually throwing it out there
like there's a huge thing that they just
know all these answers to and we don't
like my good could a long enough delay
spoil some of the not spoil and the way
we've been using it but kind of lessen
the enthusiasm for properties the way
that some have said Game of Thrones
Season eight they're maybe a little less
excited about because they've had to
wait I think we've had over saturation
quite considerably I think that's why
they're pushing back the Star Wars stuff
because they just will win BAM so hard
with that I think that they are telling
such a great story and then once the arc
is there it's like let that story kind
of wash over Union so that when this
merger does happen we can tell whole new
stories and kind of like really separate
that gap in the meantime the television
side of it all and I think you know the
fact that this story is so controversial
and you know who lives and who doesn't
ever come back the fact that we did here
far from home that Spidey's back for me
it was just like wind out of my sails it
was like why are right cool that one's
taken care of and that was the one that
hit most people the hardest I think
they're keeping mum on a lot of things
just so that you that end game can be at
its full potential it can be the most
purest form but it also sounds like
you're thinking that they are gonna take
a long break and maybe maybe even scrap
to the May 20-22
and then we'll all have to find lives
and new jobs honestly maybe I mean this
might may be his big announce because I
think what we're waiting for is for
endgame to come out obviously and it
sounds like a month later Kevin Feige is
gonna go up on a big stage somewhere and
put up a big schedule calendar list that
would be LAN and we're gonna have to
make like 80 videos out of that just
stay alive because I think hopefully
that announcement will be a big exciting
moment maybe you'll have a trailer ready
or just the announcement of the
streaming series maybe these streaming
series will be even bigger events than
what we're talking about them maybe one
of these streaming series will actually
be a movie and they've been calling it a
stringing series in order to or like you
live like a trilogy or something like
the original it for television that was
a two-night event yeah and yeah that'd
be awesome I just reminded this show is
the debrief and we
just interview each other and catch each
other up on the news of the week this
one was a little weird because it was a
realization we had about something we
don't know we realized hey nobody knows
anything that's shooting right now
wouldn't we know by now does that mean
we're about that a huge gap so the news
story you just got caught up on was that
we don't know something but it's kind of
a big deal I mean you know what's gonna
happen though d23 I think that Disney's
gonna hold all of they're not even doing
comic-con really they're making d23
there are their own comic-con yeah so I
think that's when we're gonna get all
our answers we just have to be patience
young padawan speaking of answers I
think it's time to ask questions all
right so so we're moving on to this
week's trivia question that I'm going to
ask it for us as always the loser will
have to draw from the gif of shame
reminder that Devin set up a sound board
I don't know if he's ready to use it
this week but Devin you got a sound for
trivia with the question mark which mcg
film shot under the secret title of
summer of George all of our answers are
here in the bucket as always we'll
reveal the answer later in this episode
but for now we're gonna move right on to
some other news that came out with this
week Philip you're talking about this
what have you heard
Oh guys okay do you guys remember edge
of tomorrow aka live die repeat they
actually changed it they changed it
after it came out because it performed
so poorly under edge of tomorrow because
people are like what does edge of
tomorrow mean I think it means 11:59
p.m. live die repeat way more accurately
describe that movies about and this is
the crews movie right this is a Tom
Cruise movie that was amazing it was
written by Chris McCrory I did not do
great at the box office again they have
to change the title but then because it
was so good it was a hit on streaming so
boom sequel now
in the works Emily Blunt Tom Cruise doug
liman the director all coming back oh
great this movie is like like sleepers
movie that like is everyone you show it
is like this is a blast fantastic like a
premise it's it's Groundhog Day meets a
war movie all the days is even a better
name right I don't know I still would
have watched live die repeat over Battle
of the days ooh I think this is such an
underrated movie and that people just
haven't had a chance to read it yet
because they haven't seen it came out
the same weekend as The Fault in Our
Stars and that movie made so much
audience I mean I watch both I watched I
think we saw edge of tomorrow that
weekend like the Vista theater and then
a few times it was such a great movie
and then I went to saw fall in her eyes
I'm like I would have loved this movie
too had I seen it but yeah it was uh
it's such a great movie and such a great
premise but what else is going on with
this sequel that's happened so yeah so
this time the script is being written by
Matthew Robinson he's actually the guy
who wrote the invention of line or the
Ricky Gervais smooth yeah which is the
Ricky Gervais movie were in a world
where there are no lies he's the first
person to come up with the line so one
way it is a very high concept movie so
maybe he has an interesting idea it's a
lot less action so I'm kind of a little
concerned about knowing that route with
him instead of Christopher McQuarrie who
great actually action films as a
reminder by the way and this is a big
spoiler if you haven't seen edge of
tomorrow so pause this right now and go
watch it might be under the title of die
repeat but if you don't care that movie
ends with Tom Cruise's character
successfully killing all the aliens are
known as mimics and then he wakes up one
last time and then emily Blunt's
character and others are also brought
back to life and it's kind of like hey
everybody like everything's fine now and
they have no memory of their mission or
the movie even having happened twice and
I just well nobody remembers the end of
it I think I spelled it wrong
so I think it's safe to assume that the
sequel's gonna feature more of that sort
of time looping thing going on since
that's such a main part of the original
but my question to you guys is how do
you think it's gonna do it the mimics
just reminded mimics blood is the source
of the time looping and then all those
aliens are dead so that's gonna be sold
on the black market like this if a--
crimp thing where the mimics are like
the foot soldiers right and then you
have the alphas which are like their
commandos who have the time travel
because they're linked to the central
node yeah so the way it works is Tom
Cruise who's perfectly cast in this
movie by the way acting is the whole
it's like the whole meta commentary on
how people go see Tom Cruise movies
because on some dark level we like
seeing Tom Cruise get beaten up and so
you get to see him die over and over and
over again and these movies the way a
very dark even darker version yeah
Groundhog Day but I think what what
happens in it essentially is he gets
covered in their blood and then that
blood becomes infused with his so that
every time he dies it resets all of time
so that he can start that day over I'm
thinking for a sequel we might see
something like what we see in happy
deathday to you happy deathday another
Groundhog Day premise it starts back to
the first invasion and knowing all that
he knows and he has to go and some other
ultimately as if the whole movie is it
was not done he's in just another loop
that he came in realized a broader layer
a loop a loop club sandwich if you will
is the loops just get a greater and
greater the more you zoom out yeah or
another way to see it is kind of the The
Bachelor future to just returning to the
first story again but maybe he's
heightening the steak somehow it's about
his kids maybe it's something to be done
about your kids
Suri's etiquette okay or my question is
is it gonna be kind of like whaa mod was
saying not necessarily about the aliens
are still around whatever but maybe
somebody held on some of their blood and
maybe there's like a human force that is
using that technology of being able to
reset the day for nefarious purposes
mmm-hmm yeah
that is interesting like if if you were
saying like someone else in your world
you know has the ability to restart the
day so you have to stop them from being
able yeah like a lot of these movies are
about your protagonist wakes up and
realizes oh crap I can relive the same
day again and again and then they both
do a thing where they explore like what
that means what they could do and they
try to get out of the time loop they run
amok before that I mean like when they
try to see like what they're able to do
and they try to get out of it but in
this premise and I'm pitching to be fair
off-screen producer pitch this but we
back in the pitch room is this but the
idea would be okay well what if that
person that woke up repeating the same
day is actually a bad guy Oh interesting
what an interesting villainous power
like what could be done whoops I didn't
successfully take over the world
let's hit the reset button yeah you know
I want to see like an extrapolated
version where someone who has that
ability it's not so much like Groundhog
Day or happy death day where they don't
make it past the 24 hours but in in live
die repeat or edge' tomorrow they
sometimes he lives on for weeks and then
he eventually dies and then it resets
what if someone lives their entire life
like that person has to be kept in
containment to keep the aliens from like
restarting the day and get like if they
win that war and they just keep him
alive forever and ever never and he has
to be kept in like this this bulletproof
cube
you know this boatmobile back so that no
one could ever kill him and then he dies
of old age boom the day resets yeah I
believe it to dream up currently because
I was too busy thinking if I was evil
how would I use that and why that's not
already like an x-men power oh and how
would you I went off in an if you're
watching a video you saw where I went
with that I went I went deep with it it
felt good Wow send us a gif of whatever
we missed my god well I'm glad we talked
like nerdy about that for a second
because that is one of my favorite
movies yeah but somebody fill me in now
on something that'll be me hey what's up
HBO has released character posters for
Game of Thrones this week oh boo my yeah
we've got 20 different characters
sitting on the irony
which is a who could it be who's gonna
be is it me or do they all look like
they're like are like their heads are
photoshopped onto their bodies really
bad Photoshop with you blow it up like
we have just now but the saturation that
you've done on that is just beautiful
yeah you'll see as we kind of scroll
through these but their heads all look
weird sorry that's okay I mean are they
using it from my head look I don't want
to give out any clues so they're making
it look like a bad Photoshop job either
way we still picked it apart and we're
gonna find you the little clues to dig
into like this one we've got Queen
Cersei now as a queen Queens not wearing
a crown oh yeah where's the crown a
little sweet blonde bowl-cut
going down there maybe she only wears
her crown and her YouTube videos because
it's kind of associated with her brand
but when she's not on camera she doesn't
wear the CBC rulings actually we have to
put it on I don't believe youtubers have
alternate lives and identity it's just
on camera is what we get that's one of
them do you think though that this is
like them telling us a sign maybe she's
not going to rule after all well it is
interesting right how many queens can
you have you know the war of the five
kings ask RuPaul how many Queen yeah
that is an interesting detail I think
you would think that if she's sitting on
the throne she would have her crown the
way that most of their monarchs are
wearing that thing at all times there's
a lot like 20 characters I feel like
that's the only and they're the only
people that are left in Westeros at this
stage just 20 well and here's something
the fact that not only she's not wearing
a crown but she's sharing the throne
with 19 other people that is kind of
signifying like it's up for grabs again
right yeah it's in play the haul of this
is the game of Thrones you either way no
and you die and that is the the hash tag
of the season right the for the throne
you know there you go Jon Snow
I'm supporting you with my sarcasm Jon
Snow is sitting in the exact same
position though that Ned Stark was in
the primary picture for season one who's
ripping that sword but he obviously it's
a different story because Ned Stark so
it doesn't exist anymore it's been
melted down
but he's got he's great so we're gonna
see more ghosts instead of just being on
the end of that pommel you reckon anyway
you know I'm team ghost all the way what
do you think that represents the
remembering that Ned is not even John's
dad it's his uncle that's right
but it's the patriarch of the Starks
right it's the king the king of the
north the north boom goes the king I
think that does have really that has to
be intentional in this case the way he's
holding almost sitting on the throne
yeah I mean he has carried on Ned
Stark's legacy whether or not he's as
direct lineage son he is the the
protagonist of the show now guys look
closer the belt is done the same way you
did on their crutches
yeah can you zoom in on that Devon I
think you can enhance I think if you
stretch to the corner okay
now also I want you to compare their
hands go to Jon Snow's hands because
they did something with the Photoshop
word now it makes Ned Stark look like
you have teeny tiny little hands
[Music]
[Laughter]
characters though we've got Brienne
she's got earth keeper in her hands
though which is super smart because as
we know that sword is Valyrian steel and
it is see it's the sword from the two
swords that were forged from ice being
Ned Stark's assured the other one Ilana
Jaime Lannister's got it
it's called widow's wail it used to be
his sons ow oh yeah okay and he's
heading to the north with that one so we
know for certain though there are two
swords with Valyrian steel which is
super important going into this season
we're also going to talk about Sansa
Stark she is wearing an outfit that's a
lot like the Tully's kind of attire
which is of course her mother's house
the sigil in this one is a
fish so is this meaning that's the black
fish yeah yeah oh it is a similar look
yeah and and some crimson hints of
crimson fish scales well it also could
be a dragon scale though if you swing
yeah that possibly she might not want to
bend the knee to Daenerys well not only
because she's representing the Tully's
at a time when it's it's not about
representing your old house but you know
coming together but also Brennan
blackfish is famously that's the
stubborn yeah I don't know why you know
does go with that that I see Claire that
she gave Daenerys in the teaser right
yes she's giving it now still not happy
other other characters on it though
we've got you on we have Theon where
there is also Samwell Tarly who looks
like he'd rather be anywhere else except
sitting on that iron yeah it kind of
thing where they were doing the photo
shoot and then some of the people some
of the actors actually only got called
to set or something like oh yeah go
ahead get up there turn yet these mines
for your gram that's okay yeah yeah I
did kind of have that feel there's that
yeah I don't think all these characters
are in contention if the throne but I
think the fee Matic question is like
really it's anyone's game yes I think
that's what they're trying to say right
there I want him to well let us know if
you found any clues and in these photos
there's always clues to find but yeah
but we had a bunch of news this week
right like I saw something about Walking
Dead spinoff so here's what's going on
here AMC executives let's slip that
there's another Walking Dead spin-off
series in home works now this in
addition to current existing spin-off
fear The Walking Dead and the upcoming
movies centered around Rick Grimes the
Rick Grimes left the show
he's got three movies three TV movies in
the works that some have said Danai
gurira
could show up more Maggie could play a
role in that story but for this other
new spinoff series they haven't given
away any details they haven't said
anything about the cast or the time
period of when it takes place could be
speculate though on what this new show
might be so in my case I think it could
be fun to like go the direction that the
telltale games might go that could be
fun
realistically I think they might follow
something with the governor as one of
the most popular characters like an old
story yeah an old story go back in time
and follow him because it's he's one of
the great villain I love him after he
returns after yeah we're just gonna to
me a silent film of just like this
Walker know I'd be curious to see how
like Woodbury got set up and his
backstory with his daughter there's such
a rich character who's so well portrayed
on the show and I think do if you're
gonna build an entire new series out of
it it has to be something that people
really care about so you gotta find your
Frasier and I think the Frasier this one
is the governor and you think this is
you this is your guess of what you think
they will do but I think they will do i
you know i have some speculation of what
i would really love okay so i guess
let's say on what we think they will do
yeah I think that fear The Walking Dead
was a play to a new audience potentially
like a demographic so in the Latino
community horror movies are very big and
that's why they shifted the Paranormal
Activity movies to have the but but they
had a Mexican kind of themed one it's
cocoa right the movie Coco you don't use
the pics are scary but that something is
something about that it connects with
that community at least in terms at the
box office
so it kind of wouldn't be surprised if
they do that again because that's they
do here but in a different direction so
maybe they'd go after international
audiences so maybe we'd finally see one
like an Eastern Walking Dead or
something like set in Asia oh yeah or
just another like like Geographic change
but what they're actually doing is a
demographic change yeah I mean I still
think it'd be it'd be interesting to
still keep it in relevant cultures for
some reason I'm like I don't know why I
feel like they're gonna do New Orleans
originals is setting that to what a
Montag means what is it all originals
that's been off for Vampire Diaries I
said they're too
I didn't know I love to be back it could
be fun to really get in the lore of of
the zombies or maybe we discover how the
outbreak began like scientifically this
comes into my idea which is not what
they will do but what they should do I
think if they want to get people to care
about it again they should actually
highlight the actual threat that's
happening and that's the fact that 24
countries in America now has a little
something called the zombie plague once
the zombie disease which is infecting
deer's yes start off with deals and now
it's a basically a degenerative disease
where your body wastes itself it's a
wasting disease and they've just
discovered that it can cross from D to
human so you want to talk about an
actual zombie apocalypse this is going
down and I believe that this is how do
you make people care about it because we
could be zombies very very soon so you
say make it a documentary yes half
documentary and then it's like you know
basic every time it's like these are
based on a true story name should not be
general or then it's a you could do the
walking deer just you can keep the
letters pretty much the same it just
changed the last letter and add all you
know add stretched out the line when I
painted I want to see one set in like
Eastern Europe I want to see somewhere
set in like the Middle East so you know
say it say what you really want yes wait
you really want to say what you really
want right well I want to see just other
parts of it I love this idea it's
already so post-apocalyptic down yeah
exactly
Oh that'd be so great happy blasted be
like I like the idea I've said this
before but I'm a huge fan of seeing
infrastructure crumble so I like the
idea of what the functioning actual
American government is incredibly morbid
oh I thought I was the one who was
planning like the evil plot line having
ultimate powers but you I think
an area where the government is falling
apart because of too much partisan
politics yeah I mean effect yeah darkest
hour much but also I'd be down even
though it would spoil the other ones
yeah when I'm more into the future cuz
it combines my interest of horror and
future go ahead and skip ahead to
somehow we have technology again and but
like maybe them slightly advanced I
called zombies say no more say no more
okay okay well Philip I want you to say
more but I want to move on to another
subject this whole Dark Phoenix trailer
this week yeah I don't know will you
watch I know because you know you did
the breakdown already modern if you're
if you're caught up on the details of
what we learned in this trailer oh no
because I don't know if I care oh that
was a big question right after the first
trailer a lot of people were like do we
even care about this movie especially in
the wake of the Disney Fox murder news
we were like is this movie even gonna
matter right it just does movie count is
it gonna be a dream that you know
slipped in way that I would continue it
or not and it just hit the right party
Spanish so a lot of money on yeah it's
it almost sound like they're they want
to release it I want I do want to
actually get to that topic in a minute
in a minute but oh man I said minute
someone in there here's the thing with
this trailer and I think it actually is
a reaction to people feeling like they
weren't caring about this movie there's
this huge spoiler in this trailer if you
didn't watch the trailer then this is
gonna be a spoiler for you if you did
watch the trailer they give it away very
clearly it was confirmed by the director
Simon Kinberg so this is enough warning
for you again spoiler spoiler spoiler
you've jumped out of your car by now if
you don't want to hear it sucking right
yeah tuck and roll that in this movie
spoiler alert mystique dies she is
killed by in the Dark Phoenix version of
Jean Grey and they totally gave that
away in the trailer the director said
that they did it to make sure that
people understand that Jean Grey is a
major threat now even two other x-men
that there's major consequences but a
couple things there one he said
consequences a better major so I'm
thinking that could actually be
that she's not the only one because if
they're already gonna give away one
death then it's like well how do you
starve steaks like Oh cuz other people
will die too and then I have other stops
too but first off I want to ask you guys
who else is gonna die well I mean I
always think about they see not who I
think in the comic book sense but when
contractually obviously Jennifer
Lawrence she only had a deal she wanted
out sorry bad she did not want to do the
last who have you seen how her makeup
has degraded yeah she's run out well she
didn't want to put on the body paint so
they made a suit for her to get into it
so it's like yeah she just puts on this
onesie now but she she opted out she got
locked into a really really unfortunate
contract and then she won for silver
linings playbook and took off and so
this is this is nightmare torture
situation maybe Pete Evan Evan Peters
Thank You max silver is gonna go yeah
well I mean which is unfortunate because
I think he's one he's probably the best
character of the last those are the most
memorable ones but as we know
Quicksilver is not faster than bullets
according to the MC so maybe they just
shoot him what do you think yeah I mean
if you watch the breakdown of the
trailer that I did Quicksilver is barely
in in this trailer at all
the only scenes that you really see him
in are in the Red Hook neighborhood
scenes where Jean Grey
kills mystique and there's a scene where
he runs at her and he shows up in the
school at one other point and then all
this other action that we see throughout
the movie Quicksilver is absent and I
mean I think any of these characters
could go because let's face it they're
probably just gonna reboot it's McAvoy I
don't know if we want to be around much
right he's for sure they're at least
five evidence for him not so I guess
that's my other thought is that are they
killing off mystique wanted to gain
interest in this maybe people are like
whoa this movies crazy they're gonna
kill characters off and because like mod
says a lot of people weren't caring
about this movie before this trailer I'm
kind of into it actually personally I do
I do want to see it but uh or to are
they kind of like you know what we are
gonna reboot the x-men we are giving it
over to Disney I let's go ahead and make
the x-men movie that has the balls to
kill off the x-men yeah yeah like let's
kill a bunch these characters so that's
mine
question for you guys are they going to
merge these characters over you know
they've invested multiple movies now
into these actors and these actors are
still very young they could all still
continue to play these characters a lot
of people love the James McAvoy
portrayal of magneto like are they gonna
keep them or are we gonna murder a bunch
of them and just totally recast them I
think they're gonna recast I think
they're gonna let this movie out I think
they're gonna reboot the whole thing
because yeah I mean look at what like
they've done with spider-man homecoming
right they had Tom Holland who made his
appearance in civil war like it's not
like the world was against Andrew
Garfield and these all feel like the
Andrew Garfield version but it's just
really bad timing and they're not doing
it justice so it's like do you keep
throwing money at something that's kind
of like you know half animated because
like I think part of it is a lot of
people are paying their respects to
x-men for launching this whole genre
basically for us with the original x-men
movie like that made this version of
superhero movies legit of course we had
Batman movies and Superman movies before
that but this style of x-men movie has
been kind of started this whole thing
and then they kind of almost rebooted it
when they went to first class and they
still were like oh we can't do a full
reboot even though the actors are old
let's connect it to the same universe
it's kind of like this Frankenstein
thing but let's keep sticking these dead
body parts together and like see if we
end up apocalypse it was literally
chocolates was a great example of kind
of like man you guys are feeling like
forced to do these movies but the first
class was great
I liked lots of Days of Future past it's
fantastic these are all fantastic
stories it doesn't like by rebooting it
it doesn't erase that these things
happen like I still love spider-man 2
the same Raimi's spider-man tunes for me
is like one of the best superhero ever
interesting question that just made me
think of because I think I maybe
disagree I think when you reboot a
franchise it does erase the old ones
emotionally because you just said you
love spider-man 2 and I can't remember a
thing about it anymore I mean you would
say that would you say that Ghostbusters
octopus when Ghostbusters came out that
didn't erase the original Ghostbusters
it maybe made no because it was very
much a different direction that they
took it in but now that I am i doing
Ghostbusters again maybe this version
might yeah yeah if they do
look at the Fantastic Four right like
we're dying for them to erase that from
I don't want to yeah but you're not
gonna tell me that you know when the
next Fantastic Four movie inevitably
comes out that you're still remembering
the the original version with what's his
name McMahon or man what's the name from
nip/tuck oh yeah Chris Evans I think it
all depends on the relative quality of
the movie we're in pretty uncharted
territory right this is an unprecedent
time we've never been in a situation
where superhero movies have been this
salient through pop culture and so much
we're even having this conversation I
think they can do it in the way I mean
they're gonna eventually reboot
Wolverine is that gonna make me like
Logan any less maybe not Logan but are
you gonna feel it and you can think
about it and here's actually maybe the
most pressing example the Batman movies
right Batman has been done a number of
times now and I'll say that everybody
knows that this version of Batman that
we just had with bat fly did not erase
the Dark Knight trilogy feed it the Dark
Knight trilogy I would argue did
emotionally erase the Tim Burton trilogy
for some old movies I think I think
that's a good example of like my point
of view on this like I can still rewatch
this nostalgic Lee maybe but you don't
feel like those are the Batman movies
and that's always gonna be a case for
every new generation of fans who takes
on a property like it's the same thing
of people who are young who are just
watching the force awakens in the last
Jedi now those are their Star Wars movie
they're gonna have the same attachment
to the old ones just because that's why
they're re-releasing these so that like
new generations of people can love what
they like it's a completed story you
know I think we are yeah we are invested
when it's a continual story but once
that sort of trilogy would ever want it
when it's done that kind of ends for you
so so I'm gonna throw out there then if
it is about the completion of the story
by the way I'm not saying that it's a
bad thing right like I'm I don't I think
we could do the x-men better than we've
done them so I'm okay with emotionally
letting go of the previous version but
I'll just throw out there if you're like
yeah why wouldn't you be that everything
you guys just said would argue then that
we could totally reboot the Marvel
Universe right now too because we just
completed their story and I think we
could I think that's fine no and those
people be close to death that's why
there's such a long
between them and there's clever ways you
can work around this too if you look at
what JJ Abrams did with Star Trek right
he found this interesting time-travel
can see where they were still able to
get Spock the original Spock to come
back and still be part of this and
continue this storyline using some you
know time-travel mechanics there's ways
that we can think outside the box and
keep them preserve what we loved about
the old timeline and time-travel so yeah
and multiverses will say I'm really
curious what you guys say about this in
the comments just generally like almost
like in terms of voting does a reboot of
our franchise for you not literally but
does it emotionally kind of replace the
previous franchise for you yeah even if
you don't want it to so for example for
me I'm really nervous about the buffy
reboot you know I love the original
there's another one coming I almost
don't want it to happen because I'm
scared interesting debate what else did
happen this week well got a bit of other
news in a segment we call you know there
are news Will Smith is officially out of
Suicide Squad for the recall day oh wow
I wonder why because he's too busy being
blue as inexpensive Viola Davis oh is
back in she's in she's yeah I really
like definitely need Amanda Waller we
got Finn wolf hard is in talks to star
in the new Ghostbusters movies this
makes no sense to me it's not thinking
outside the box at all because he was
literally in stranger things dressed up
as a Ghostbusters me it's just like well
stranger things have happened
yeah quick why is always catch my sketch
ah the only sound you put on at least an
you need streaming it's got a universe
mode where you can see a bunch of
deleted scenes including a new
spider-ham sequence that happens at the
beginning we got a jump on that I can't
do that maybe five more times yeah it's
such a great rewatch we got we got a
video coming out it's like other more
deep details in Easter eggs that we even
missed the first time we caught it that
we were able to look at now that we have
digital and we can like pause it and
look at it so yeah I'm excited to talk
about that again Kevin Feige has
clarified that the upcoming Marvel
Disney Plus series will definitely tie
in directly with the MCU movie
Oh like witches is doesn't sound like
news until you realize the Netflix once
did not yeah so it's actually saying
like no these will count even agents of
shield hopefully more than agents of
shield they were just kind of lately
yeah and then the Warner Brothers
chairman Kevin Harris a so effortlessly
and yet I am he making a fool out of
myself told an interview that the DC EU
is not focusing on a larger connected
universe for now okay that's probably
for the day and they're doing Marvel in
Reverse where they did Ensemble and then
now they're realizing that the
individual movies are all which maybe it
wasn't their strategy to begin with like
I think it's better for these characters
you actually have a bevy I love using
bevy of interesting characters in the DC
Comics that you want to explore in their
own movies you don't have to rely on a
miniature interconnected universe that
Marvel Comics did is in the top five
highest grossing movies of all time at
the moment internationally with with
international yeah it's huge yeah so I
go and do each character justice and
then put them into a league we have to
do the characters justice and then but
give us flashpoint give us an egg wing
movie you know yeah you know and just
like focus on these stories right and
then we have yeah Aquaman 2 is coming
down 2022 yes yeah just good on you
what's the name again mod Kevin Suzy her
we're gonna move on to our new Rex
there's news lightning round lightning
round
underground because lightning doesn't
have a sound so these questions are we
ready mine
I'm agent 14 on the Himalaya app thanks
for using Himalaya one snow do you think
endgame will open with Louis recapping
the MC okay so like Iron Man yes Phillip
at I are at like daisies wants to know
what's a personal film theory that you
keep a secret from everyone else a
personal film theory that I keep secret
from that is not a lightning question by
the question I can't tell you mine [ __ ]
down from the heavens at Devi word AB
let's know what movie do you like that
everyone says it's awful or bad - Speed
Racer Shh
ooh what's the movie that I like that I
think it's people say it's bad Mortal
Kombat and Street Fighter let's see I
really liked the you know what I know a
lot people say this is bad especially if
you watch this channel but a lot of
people think Doctor Strange is like one
of the worst Marvel films like if you
have to compare them Doctor Strange is
my favorite Marvel film i hands-down it
is my favorite Marvel film I love that
movie yeah so there you go there's an
answer I just think it's great I love
everything about love to iron man 3 -
that's up there - I think it's worse
than three mod @e rod eight to six
months - no for anyone so he's not just
for you but who's going to be the one to
tell Jon Snow the truth about his
parentage brand Sam or someone else I
like Branagh cuz he knows everything and
like we're just saying with the Dark
Phoenix thing it's like we have to blend
a bomb so that you know how powerful
someone is I think that's a pretty good
one yeah I think he was it yeah bran has
no emotional awkwardness he'll just be
like yeah you're you're the not your dad
by the way dad's totally not roasting by
the way the album comes out next week
soon Philip yeah a true genius wants to
know since Gilley or either
since Gilly is either aunt / sister /
news / president / possibly mother to
all the White Walkers who were
originally cast her sons could she
become the potential perfect night queen
candidate Gilly chapters yeah no no no
because also he casters children did
make White Walkers but he's he's younger
than their race right yeah just a long
before yeah so they were probably just
kidnapping wild lanes before that do it
for me at GOC Rahm wants to know will we
learn the secrets of the faceless men in
the last season of Game of Thrones I
think not I think they the show has said
everything they're gonna say about the
faceless men I could be interesting if
if they came back into it especially you
know if aria has some comeuppance but we
have six episodes left I think they're
gonna focus on the tasks set and and I
don't I don't know if I really need the
faceless men to come back and actually
at FEMA wants to know do you think not
even jaqen H'ghar will come back I think
it'd be interesting if he did show up to
pay some kind of debt but I think we've
seen everything we're gonna see for him
I think the show wants to move on so I'm
gonna say no and it might show up in
next year's what we got wrong Maude I
thought miss monster was to know what
are the chances that cables time-travel
device is the same altered technology
from in-game what are the chances 46
percent that's pretty good thank you can
I give it and fill up a Teddy c89 was to
no seriously where is Gabe and you
answer you'll have the same fate whose
cabe eric is completely compatible with
with other white guys on the channel
that's right
and moving on to some other things we
got yes let's wrap this sucker up guys
let's get let's just get to our 15
second shoutouts I'm excited cuz this
time actually remember mine
so each was gonna have 15 seconds to
shout out one two and it's a ramble
about anything they want Sam why don't
you start alright so for me if we could
put 15 seconds on the clock great just a
reminder that there's gonna be a card
Star Trek series that just focuses on
Picard now I think it's like nineteen
years or something after the previous
thing he's just like carnies Picard
which I love because that means they're
not gonna like recast him as some
somebody else so just a reminder it's
worth it great
I want to shout out to Black Milk it's a
good label that started in Brisbane I'm
wearing it right now they've just
released said new range which is Rick
and Morty and they sent me a bunch of
stuff and it's awesome I'm gonna take a
photo and put it on my Instagram but
while I'm at it I'm also gonna talk
about shop what which is my label it
looks a lot like like milk but it's not
because it's for guys and girls and
there's a new range and there's three
new designs that we just dropped it's
awesome one second spin but also real
quick shop what is spelled owh UT for
what it's and so we have unlimited
talent Oh check that out new designs
never seen before it's like a sneaky
anagram for them Eric that was your time
the proper saying I'm probably gonna
plug my show I'm not gonna plug my show
because it's tonight it's already out
there in the world I'll do that next
week for now I'm gonna plug someone made
an amazing video version and they
animated our live reading of dog lovers
Deadpool script
it looks fantastic they did such a great
job I'm gonna tweet it out go see on my
Twitter page give that person lots of
views cuz they did an amazing job thank
you for doing that yes you are yeah well
I have to do that one but we're
returning to our trivia question that's
the one I certainly did ask it now
remember if you do not get close to the
answer if you is the most embarrassingly
far away miss of the answer no no I mean
you will have to reach into the gift of
shame and perform that task and it's
gonna be on a green screen so people can
humiliate and manipulate and exploit you
for the rest of your life green screen
thank God because I have a career that I
really want to last
I'll see you like wearing the same shade
of green behind it I didn't think about
that
in hindsight that's probably really
brilliant but the question was again
which MCU film was shot under the secret
title of summer of George Eric reckons
it was guardians of the galaxy Philip
said of interest age of Ultron and Maude
said a Winter Soldier sama
of George but it wasn't at all guys it
was spider-man homecoming none of us
arrived at homecoming so it's gonna be
who Devon in all right so if you're
listening to this on a podcast and
you've just heard this nonsense right
now go pull over and then pull up our
Twitter I wrote all these guys oh yeah
that one's a men's only one so you can
follow us on twitter at new rosters and
you'll be able to see what this I gif is
but I think you guys so much for
watching Maude what are you gonna do for
us I'm a real boy now not quite
Pinocchio and I'm so glad I pulled it
out because I couldn't spell it and I
have to apologize for the spelling of it
has he strings attached
still your Pinocchio but you have your
strings attached it's very in sync all
right so yeah no strings attached
semi album from the preeminent boy band
the early 2000 and sync uh not a weird
flex are very proud flex I want to thank
our host Maude Garrett at Maude Garrett
she's doing this tonight you're probably
gonna start a fight Philip Malina is me
at FEMA take over and Eric Foss a ta vas
you can follow all of us on there hey go
check out my Instagram I'm trying to be
forced to use it
it's ballina a reminder that you can
watch this on
YouTube but you can listen to it in an
audio form anywhere you get podcast
please sit on Himalaya the videos
youtube.com slash turn rock stars and
then you can also by the way leave
comments on the Himalaya app as you
could see they could end up in the
lightning round Eric what are you doing
get that Eric out of the way alright
this always devolves into nonsense but
that's that's our show give it a like
give it a share it gives it a subscribe
and we'll see you next time oh man that
dang soundboard
[Music]